what happened when you were caught that
first time so I was caught I got three
years probation you know I took the
probation what does that involve
initially it
was it was such a slap on the hand on
the wrist were you allowed to still
practice okay so I wasn't I had to I
couldn't own the mortgage company
anymore mhm that was a good question cuz
like you would think you know wouldn't
it be great if I could keep on going
um but what they said was you know you
you have to forfeit your your brokerage
um your broker's license and your
brokerage business license and what I
did was I I transferred my brokerage
business license to a guy that
essentially bought my
business they allowed me to work as a
consultant in the mortgage industry you
know cuz they went you know they go my
my lawyer goes to the judge and says
what else can he do so
um and so I have a friend name's Dave
Walker he was a CPA he came in and he
bought my business and he paid me like
$9,000 a month and that covered my bills
uh my wife and I got divorced so she's
my ex-wife
and I I don't know what to do right like
I don't I'm I could you know and I
always say you know I could have like
you know you look back and it's like I
could have claimed
bankruptcy um I could have moved into my
parents spare room you know something
like that but you know because I had I
had I lost everything in my divorce um I
had huge child support payment um you
know not that that has anything to do
like with my my ex-wife like I
absolutely signed up for that like I
wanted to pay that um but it was it was
it was a chunk of change you know so
we're talking about a couple thousand
dollars a month for you know for child
support um she got all of the apartments
that we had we had about a million
million and a half dollars worth of
Apartments which isn't a lot now but
that's probably five or6 million now so
she got all the apartment so she got
everything so now I'm sitting here like
I got I can't be a mortgage broker I can
get my $9,000 but I have to help this
guy run this company train people do
that sort of thing so what I decided to
do was I was going to start flipping
houses legitimately or not well
initially I thought about doing it um
legitimately right but at the same time
I was also in the middle of figuring out
how to make these synthetic
identities so I'm making the payments
every month remember two months in three
month no no credit scores no credit
scores no credit scores and I'm also
saying I'm going to go I'm going to
start buying houses renovate them sell
them so to the the truth is we actually
renovated probably one house completely
I remember it was on 26th Street we
renovated the house completely
completely on the outside in and the
inside yeah outside inside it's done
it's good okay great um me and me and
this guy actually Dave Dave Walker the
guy that bought my business so we
renovate it and it just so happens at
the same time I go to pull credit one
day and wow 700 Plus credit scores and I
went we don't have to sell this thing at
all like we just we just I can sell it
and put it in this guy's name and let
him refinance it and so that's what we
did we ended up I ended up selling it to
this synthetic identity do you remember
the first synthetic identity the name
the first one was a Joel cologne yeah
and then I started getting creative
because the ones after that I started
naming so I had like Joel cologne and an
allen Duncan but then I I do you
remember the movie Reservoir
Dogs so I I started naming the
characters after guys in the reservoir
dogs so I I had a I had a a James red
you know I had a like a Michael White a
Lee
black I had a um William blue David
silver uh Brandon green so then I start
developing these guys now I thought oh
forget those those normal names I'm
going with these with the reservoir dogs
and I thought I was so cute too you
think in retrospect that was a mistake
it was so stupid that was just it's
there's so many things so many mistakes
I made I
mean within the fraud there are mistakes
I made but you know other than just the
overall committing fraud but it was just
like I thought it was so cute and then
you know you get in front of the judge
and the judge is hearing about the
reservoir dogs and Mr Mr Green Mr Black
Mr White Mr this Mr that and he's
looking at me just like you jackass like
and you know what am I saying I'm like
yeah I thought that was cute um you know
but nothing's cute so you know plus I'm
making fake Banks what's the purpose of
the fake Banks well sometimes you have
to have your down payment in the bank
right so you have they have to they want
three months worth of bank statements to
see that hey he's got his $50,000 in the
bank and then the more the more
properties you buy they want start to
want to see what's called reserves they
want to make sure that you can pay all
your mortgage
payments if this guy loses his job can
this guy maintain all these mortgage
payments for the next six months and see
they do that and they think you're going
to go you know oh no he can't do it they
go well then we won't lend it well when
they do that to me I go of course I do
of course he's got it let me send you
over the bank f uh bank statements oh
you want to call the bank call them so
there's a phone number there's a website
yes you can call we'll get on there I'll
I'll do the
whole you know and uh hold on okay uh
what's the name again do you have the
account
number hold on you wait a little bit you
know you come back oh okay I got it here
I I can't tell you the exact amount
right now but what is the what what was
his balance last month and the theya oh
yep that that's it exactly okay thank
you click would you do different voices
or would you be I've done different
voices or I just have somebody else do
it you know Gretchen would have done it
or um or one of the Brokers Susan would
have done it one of the Brokers that
worked for me or you know Kelly or
Johnny moon or I I have so many guys and
you know they just get on the phone they
do it because they're all doing
something fraud and we're all working
together so hey I need you to call this
guy I need to call this guy and verify
this and say I'm at the bank okay I'm at
the bank okay cool and they call back
and do this feel like an organized
system or was it more improv just like
dealing with the different situations
the government would definitely say it
was organized I always say it was you
know you're a bunch of you're just a
bunch of guys you know to you know it's
you're joking around with everybody and
you're you're helping each other and
it's not like everybody's you know
kicking up to Tommy yeah you know so so
and then all these new puzzles come up
and you figure out way to these puzzles
you go in and you say hey I've got I've
got this loan I need to get this loan
and this guy's trying to buy this house
and I need a loan that looks like this
where can we go and by the way way they
cannot they cannot order a copy of his
tax returns so you don't want to have to
sign what's called a 4506 so they're
like okay listen so and so's got a
program that you know and you go back
and but you have to have this much in
reserves but you got the bank right yeah
yeah I got the bank I could do that you
know so you you go in and you throw it
out there to five or six guys and you're
going to come up with an
answer